These are the solar power towers of southern
Spain.
This is one of the sunniest parts of Europe,
and these were two of the first solar towers
ever built.
Almost 2,000 heliostats, movable mirrors,
constantly reflect the sun onto the towers,
heating up water into steam,
and powering a turbine to generate electricity.
And if you look online,
you'll see quite a few documentaries who've
gotten a tour around there,
who've been incredibly impressed by the technology,
and who've been selling them as the future
of power generation.
And these are impressive.
Not just visually,
the technology behind them is both very clever
and very simple:
it's like bothering your teacher with the
sunlight reflection off your phone,
just on a much, much bigger scale.
But there is a catch.
When these were built, Spain was in boom times,
and heavily subsidising solar power.
Investors loved it and piled in with their
own money,
companies and researchers were happy to set
up all sorts of things like this,
and suddenly the Spanish government had many
times the amount of solar power they'd planned for...
and they had to subsidise all of it.
And then the financial crash hit.
The Spanish government cut subsidies.
Not just for the future,
not just for the plants that were under construction,
but even for the plants that were already
built
and relying on those subsidies to balance the books.
The industry got cold feet: Spain had altered
the deal,
and all the solar companies could do was pray
they didn't alter it any further.
Or go bankrupt, one of the two.
This might still have been viable, maybe,
with some more research and development,
and that's what they were trying to do.
But now, the cost of regular,
everyday solar panels is tumbling.
Not mirrors, not like this,
just normal solar panels, the sort that you can fit to your house
or that get put out in massive fields as solar farms,
converting sunlight directly to electricity.
Whether the price of those panels is going
to keep falling
depends on which team of researchers you believe,
but it's already cheaper than building a giant
tower,
putting in either high pressure water or molten
salt for it to heat,
and dealing with thousands of moving parts
that all have to line up and track the sun
perfectly
and which might, occasionally, cook a few
birds in mid-flight.
Don't get me wrong, this is a great bit of
technology on paper.
It combines renewable energy with storage:
if you're heating up something like molten
salt,
you can save that power for hours to get you
through the night.
And there are other plants like it being built:
there's one nearly completed in the Atacama
Desert in South America.
But right now,
this is expensive.
It might not have been,
if history had taken a different track,
if research had poured into these instead
of regular solar panels: but as it is,
the future probably isn't quite this bright.